joining me here on the rich eisen show
getting set for the season finale in so
far stadium against the san francisco
49ers for his new team the los angeles
rams is the man who is the mvp of super
bowl 50 a perennial pro bowler and all
pro now with the rams he is von miller
how you doing vaughn i'm doing pretty
good i'm i'm just hanging out in la and
uh it definitely does not suck me in
here
it's a little warmer a little warmer
climbs huh it's a little bit it's a
little warmer um you know golf you can
play golf year-round
um the light's a little bit brighter but
let's steal football at the end of the
day okay well let me hit you with the
the burning question of uh did you bring
your chickens with you
did y'all
i left him in texas i didn't bring her
with me it was i mean it was so last
minute and it was so
you know spread the moment that um you
know i had
you know chickens were they were on the
last they were the last thing on my mind
when i came to l.a okay uh have you uh
then than a father just a brief
follow-up um have you named any of your
chickens mcvay or donald uh no i haven't
you know hopefully this uh this playoff
run you know i have a lot of a lot of
chickens named after you know my my
teammates on this team okay
so how uh then let's get to the football
i i had to ask about the chickens first
so uh so the the football aspect of it
are you where where are you in your
comfort level your readiness uh for a
playoff run that you know
what it takes to win it all through
there um you know i'm comfortable and um
i'm comfortable in this team
you know we went to the super bowl in
2015 and this team has a lot of those
similarities you know um to be honest
this team is is probably more talented
than that uh that 2015 team you know we
got jalen ramsey aaron donald
we got uh leonard leonard floyd you know
myself you know our offensive line on on
this team is is definitely more
experience and more season
um you know we got a whole stable
running backs we got cooper cup
you know the best wide receiver in the
league this this team has a tremendous
amount of talent but what really what
really sets what really
you know gets me going it gets me
excited about this team than you know
the 2015 team is you know really the way
we handle adversity um the way we handle
you know the odds being against us um
you know these last couple of games
um we threw i think it was two pick we
had three turnovers in the last game we
were able to come out and win it on the
game before that
um you know we uh through uh three
interceptions as well we're able to we
were able to hold the lead and win that
as well then the week before that we
threw uh two intersections and now you
don't want to throw as many
interceptions you don't want to turn the
ball over but
you know whatever odds are presented
against this team we we somehow find a
way to overcome it and you know you
don't want to make it tougher than it
has to be that's for sure but you know
i'm pretty excited about this team and
the way we handle adversity well i mean
you know in terms of comparing this team
to to that super bowl 50 team you know
when you say this team may be talented
you know that you might you might hear
from the sheriff on that one um
you know peyton manning is always going
to be paid away you know that's always
going to be my favorite quarterback
that's always going to be
my favorite quarterback ever you know in
any debate against any other hall of
fame quarterback i'm gonna always ride
with peyton manning i'm just uh i'm just
talking about you know the core and the
foundational players that team was
talented it really was talented we won
nine games within three points or less
um that season
um this team you know they're um you
know they're ready to go you know we got
to get to the playoffs when we get in
the playoffs we got to continue to
handle adversity and somehow find a way
to string these uh these games together
well um have you learned ron miller here
on the rich eisen show what have you
learned if anything about aaron donald
that you didn't already know that you
now know and can share with me and
everyone else here um you know
i've always been a fan of football you
know and i've always studied the greats
you know how and and why you know what
makes them great you know what uh
you know what what makes you know aaron
donald gets uh you know sack after sack
season after season and um you know
there's nothing like actually being here
and seeing it you know this guy is the
same guy
you know he has that intensity that he
has on the football field
24 7 owning out the football fit of
course you know he opens up and he
laughs with the guys but you can always
tell us one thing on the line it's one
thing on his mind and that's being great
that's one thing on his mind is is
making game
changing plays you know weekend and week
out you know i get to see it i play
right on the left side of them you know
i get a tackle for loss i'm thinking i'm
about to make the tackle for loss and
then 99 comes out of nowhere and just
engulfs the guy and you know he's just
like he's like a great white shark and
his blood in the water man any play that
there is to be made from inside outside
past double team triple team slide
you know he is he is definitely the real
deal no matter what offensive show adam
no matter what offenses throw at him and
you know i've seen the way he practices
i've seen the way he focuses in meetings
you know i've seen you know the way you
know his teammates you know respect them
and you know it's very well earned and
you know he's just the beast on and off
the football field and it's been an
honor privilege to be his teammate so he
snagged some uh tackles from la for loss
from you like you think here we go i
mean
the ball it it didn't come to me yet i'm
just waiting on the outside thinking i'm
gonna have a chance to make this play
and then you just see 99 shoot up the
middle and and just uh you know dash all
those hopes for me and you know it's
been refreshing you know it's definitely
been refreshing playing with a guy like
you know aaron donald i've had some
great teammates throughout my whole
entire career you know i've had uh
played with demarcus square and edward
stewartville sean phillips
um
chad bailey you know i play with so many
different you know hall of fame you know
type players
and um you know i think you know aaron
donald's definitely gonna be a hall of
famers it's just so refreshing you know
having a d tackle you know for once one
of the best steve tackles to ever play
the game and i get to play football with
him and um it's it's crazy because at
the beginning of the season you know me
and uh bradley chubb we were talking
about you know games and football and
stuff and i was like man
you know if i could play with a guy like
aaron this is where i was still in with
the denver broncos this is like during
training camp like man if i could play
with a guy like
you know aaron donald or we had a guy
like aaron donald that's just going to
eat up those double teams and shoot up
the field man we have 100 sacks and you
know it's crazy how you just speak stuff
into existence and you know eight weeks
later i get traded to los angeles rams
and you know it hurt at first but um
you know it's kind of like pulling out a
splinter you know it hurts when you pull
out the splinter but you know every day
after that it just gets better and
better and it feels it starts to feel
good and you start to think about the
possibilities of playing with aaron
donald and his team and this coaching
staff and his offense that we have man
and like i said before when we when we
first started this this interview man it
definitely does not suck being here and
it's a it's an honor and a privilege
being here and i'm excited about it well
he kind of you kind of touched on that
so i guess again
you know you are where you are and
clearly you seem so happy and you seem
excited about what's going on there but
why did it have to happen
do you think for you to be in los
angeles from denver i you know i don't
you know i don't know and
you know i'm sure you know i'm sure it's
probably had something to do with my
contract or you know not being able to
you know not being in the plans for next
season to sign you back or you know
whatever whatever reason it was at the
end of the day you know denver
definitely did it right by me um they
sent me to
you know los angeles rams one of the
best teams in the nfl one of the best
teams in the nfc they were going to the
playoffs and they sent me to a good team
to make a good team better and plus they
they didn't have to do it the way they
did it you know i paid the rest of my
salary they could have sent me off to
the jets or
sent me off to another team that's
rebuilding you know they could have sent
me to the jags you know for you know
whatever they wanted to do but you know
they sat and thought about what's best
for me and i and i you know they told me
that but i definitely feel that and i
definitely believe that you know they
sent me here to the los angeles rams and
they paid the rest of my salary it
wasn't about money it was just about
what's good for um the denver broncos
and what's good for me and you know i've
all had the utmost respect for george
payton and john elway and um they
definitely they definitely did it right
by me and i appreciate those girls so
avon miller here on the rich asset show
what about the long-term future of you
there in los angeles have you talked
about it do you do you want to do it
like what do you what do you think you
know i still have a lot of football left
i still feel like i can still play i
still feel like i can rush i'm still
running with the young guys um you know
la it definitely
it definitely does not suck being here
um you know i've always spent a lot of
time here in la
um i'm very familiar with la and you
know
how it is being a you know a big fish in
a big pond like this you know i'm very
familiar with you know how things work
and how things go and
you know i would love to be here you
know i would love to who wouldn't want
to play where donald you know for the
rest of that career who wouldn't you
know want to play with jalen ramsey and
you know matthew stafford and all these
other guys who won't want to you know
have coach mcveigh you know coach him
and it's crazy this is the first time in
my whole career where i've actually been
older than my position coach you know uh
bulgaris my position coach
i'm actually
a month and two days older than him so
it's uh it's a different dynamic being
here i'm a vet and this guy kind of
feels like when demarcus came to the
denver broncos now i'm that demarcus on
this team so
you know i love being in l.a i love la
and you know we just you know have to
figure everything out in the off-season
you know when you win super bowls it
kind of you know everything kind of
works itself out anyway and
you know whatever opportunity i can get
whatever opportunity i'm presenting with
man you know i would love to you know
take advantage of it so obviously you
got a one more regular season game to go
in which you can
then make sure that you play the next
week in sofi if not the next maybe two
weeks and so far
um and who knows
from there where that's where the super
bowl is are you guys openly discussing
hey last year
the bucks did it why can't we do it why
can't we do what the bucks did last year
which is win in our own building you
talking about that
no we now we haven't talked about of
course you know we're
you know we
we know that the super bowl is gonna be
here and you know we're aware of that
but right now we're just we're just
about taking it one week at a time you
know this this team has been so even
killed throughout the losses throughout
the wins they just you know the same
group of guys we come into we do the
same we do the same things the same
sense of humor um everybody's confident
and what they can do everybody's
confident and and who they are from the
players to the coaches to you know the
media staff to the trainers you know
everybody is just so even keel and
everybody expects to win and everybody's
confident that we can win that you know
we just take it one week at a time and
we just take each and every opportunity
um and we we compartmentalize it as its
own individual opportunity and we just
take advantage of it man it's it's been
refreshing i mean you do feel refreshed
i mean i'll be honest with you i get the
sense that you're totally jacked up for
this yeah i am you know
you know usually i get nervous before
games and you know um when i was with
denver broncos i would get nervous not
in a sense that i was afraid or anything
like i wasn't sure of myself it's just i
want to go out there and i want to
be the best be the best vomit that i
could possibly be i want to go out there
and make this be the best game that i
ever played and i still feel like that
but the nerves and anxiety it kind of it
kind of subsides when i look to my right
and i see aaron donald i look behind me
and i see
jaylen ramsey and i see leonard floyd
across and i see coach mcveigh coaching
and the other side you got odell beckham
cooper cup you know it just it just you
know it puts me at peace where you know
i just got to do what i do and the best
thing that i do more than anything else
in this in this world you know i play
golf you know i'm a comedian you know um
yeah i gotta laugh right there
i mean you gotta stand up back are you
are we gonna see you we gonna see you
you know maybe post covert knock on wood
you know do do a set or two here in l.a
on something yeah i mean that'd be good
man that'd be good man you know i dj too
and i do all these things great but the
one thing that i do better than all of
these things is rush to passer and here
with the demo here with the los angeles
rams all i have to do is focus on
russian a passer and it's it's been
refreshing man i love it
von thanks for the time let's do it i'd
love to have you in studio because you
know i'm la based too you know where i
am yeah
i'd love to come back yeah we had you on
with jim gaffigan you could we you know
he that one day you wore he he you put
on this
major i mean i don't know if you have
stuff that necklace the bling that he
put on and yeah i still got it i stick
all that yeah okay he still got it and
then you know uh he could have given you
tips for stand up and everything so
let's do it i could do it we could we
could put it back together sure
we set it up hopefully you know um you
know championship right after that we
play in a an nfc championship man we can
set some up
you know it'd be good let's do it okay
thanks for the time that's von miller
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here